PROFESSOR: I was an
undergrad at MIT.
And I majored in both economics
and management.
And while I was taking classes
in these subjects, I also had
the chance to tutor and teach
the subjects for a couple of
semesters over a couple
of years.
And while I was tutoring and
teaching the subject, what I
noticed is that there were a
number of problems that would
always trip up students in
certain and specific ways.
And so what I'm hoping to do
in these problem-solving
videos is I'm hoping to take
some of the more difficult
problems from the PSETS, and
take you through the
solutions, so that these
problems that come up won't
affect you.
And what we're going to do is
I want you to not just take
away a quantitative solution
to the problem.
But more specifically, I want
you to be able to take that
quantitative solution, link it
to a conceptual understanding
through figures and diagrams,
and ultimately build a greater
intuition about economics
principles in general.
I hope you enjoy the videos,
and I look forward to
working with you.